empecemos por hablar de Por qué señalan
a Torres de omisión y cómo se relaciona
esto con el hecho de que las autoridades
de Brasilia permitieran que los
bolsonaristas acamparan A las afueras
del cuartel del ejército desde las
elecciones del año pasado
porque
unos tres mil simpatizantes del
expresidente
invadieron como tú decías los palacios
de la presidencia del Congreso y el
supremo tribunal Federal sin que
prácticamente haya habido oposición de
las fuerzas policiales fuerzas
policiales de Brasilia desde donde te
hablo que estaban en ese momento bajo
las órdenes de Torres quien además de
haber sido acusado de omisión es
sospechada de algún nivel de complicidad
con el expresidente bolsonaro con quien
se encontraba hasta hace un par de días
en Florida en el sur de Estados Unidos
Estados Unidos desde Estados Unidos se
la arribó hoy a la mañana aquí a la
capital e inmediatamente fue arrestado
por orden de supremo tribunal Federal de
manera que aquello que hace algunos días
en una sospecha se convirtió en una
denuncia de la fiscalía denuncia por los
demás considerada verosímil por la
máxima corte brasileña Le quiero
preguntar sobre ese encuentro entre
bolsonaro y Torres quien además fue
ministro en el gobierno de bolsonaro
bolsonaro está en Orlando Mientras que
el exegetario dice que estaba en Miami
de vacaciones realmente se encontraron
las informaciones a las que tenemos
acceso aquí de parte de medio brasileños
con corresponsales en Estados Unidos así
lo indican por lo demás no parece
extraordinario que se hayan encontrado
porque Torres fue durante más de dos
años ministro de justicia de bolsonaro y
durante casi una década una personalidad
muy próxima cuando el expresidente fue
diputado federal digamos que Torres es
algo así como un miembro de la mesa más
cercana del Poder del expresidente por
tanto esa proximidad existe comprobada
está documentada y el encuentro resulta
algo muy probable añadimos a eso que
poco después de que se ordenara el
arresto de el ex ministro de seguridad
de aquí de Brasilia la Corte Suprema
también incluyó a Jair bolsonaro en un
proceso en el que se lo considera
hipotéticamente instigador del intento
de golpe de estado ocurrido hace seis
días y después de esa toma de hace seis
días y en medio de estos procesos
judiciales qué tan fuerte estaba la
extrema derecha en Brasil
tal vez más que fuerte fortísima porque
la semana pasada demostraron tener una
capacidad de convocatoria y de
movilización y de acción violenta
sorprendentes y estos se une a que
tengamos en cuenta hace poco más de dos
meses bolsonaro obtuvo 58 millones de
votos en un duelo muy parejo vencido por
Lula en un balotazo vencido por ulular
con 60 millones de manera que apenas dos
millones menos que el presidente
actualmente en funciones quiere decir
esto que todo el lector de bolsonaro
está dispuesto a dar un golpe de estado
o a asaltar y saquear los principales
Palacios públicos no pero que el
respaldo es muy fuerte y estos son los
lectores de derecha y simpatizantes
entre ellos
comprometidos con acciones radicales